and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
thank you guys thanks for coming out
there's Tim forgot to order chairs
yeah his podcast I panicked I looked at
her I'm like are there no chairs Ted I'm
a professional broadcaster I must have a
chair yeah I mean look at what a nice
chair they got for us
yeah they spared no expense thanks guys
for coming out we were worried that the
venue wouldn't have huge windows with a
lot of light good it did
peering in but thank God so this is your
first a a meeting welcome Tim and I both
have been sober for over six hours yes
and we're excited to bring you here to
spread the word of positivity yes this
is a cool what do you think about Austin
Ron what do I think about all what do
you think like controversial right up
front I'm gonna go this far it's a city
in Texas is that what we're looking for
I gotta be honest I concur
what do you it's weird to me I don't got
it's it's it's a place you don't get
well I don't normally most places I go
there's not scooters on the sidewalk
right that I'm [ __ ] dodging what was
the idea there it's too safe to walk
around here you know there's not enough
minorities so let's do something
ourselves I will computers on the
sidewalk not enough minorities put some
terrifying white people you guys you
guys have done that you have taken your
white people and really you run with it
you spice them up yeah can I just say
this I don't think we need camouflage
inside City Limits
it gives me it's a nerve-racking feeling
like there's some Mad Max thing that I
don't understand that's going down at
any second do I need camouflage yeah
it's like do everybody's a doomsday
prepper and right
it's weird cuz you'll walk around this
place and you'll say to somebody you'll
be like is that a homeless shelter and
they'll be like no it's the
highest-rated restaurant in the state
right
this is the number one difference right
from New York and Austin yeah is our
homeless people are sick and ill yes not
incredibly great shape right and able to
chase you down the street riding for
money yeah I don't ever want to be
outrun by a homeless person I want my
homeless person to have a scary rash
here that I don't understand at all here
they leap off the ground like I've seen
two of them literally leap up off the
ground yeah in a maneuver that I could
never attempt
well that's because you didn't live the
matrix and yes that's all about that
matrix homeless people here they're just
in fabulous shape by the way they will
work for food sign I just want to say
yes that's the basic theory of all
capitalism yeah this is what we're all
doing working for food so like when we
go on a job interview and we can't say
okay you're not hiring me can you give
me a few bucks no it doesn't work that
what no it's it's amazing to watch I
also like they don't have a lot of like
another thing I was I was here for South
by Southwest a few years ago when I was
sick in there's like New York we have a
drug store every other storefront is a
drug store right but here they don't
have that here they have like
apothecaries they have like right old
1950s style drug Mart's that close at
4:00 p.m. you know you can't get [ __ ]
poeple at all right you have a guy
actually grinding up the drugs yeah you
know we have machines to do it yeah well
the mortar and pestle yeah they have
their own uber service because you I
think oh it's over stuff and at the
airport here now right is it still no
but you can't get an uber at the airport
look oh they're back okay good that's
service you had didn't hold up yeah
that's service if it was just like a
which would pull up with a van yeah
there's a wagon train more than event
like too much into the Western thing
yeah and by the way is this the west or
the south you gotta make up your mind
you can't have both yeah what's good
mean by a-plus how many people think
this is the West by applause and how
many people think they're in this south
south is it winter weather clear we're
in the south yeah congratulations near
winter to the Confederacy
yeah which got the silver medal not a
lot of people bring that up but they
still they silver in the Civil War they
didn't gradual ations yeah I thought
they would have gotten endorsement deals
you know that's absolute if take away
nothing else from this podcast that the
Confederacy got the silver that's what
we want you guys to take away I'm not I
think barbecue and a lot of people are
gonna get man here because they base
their identity on this sadly yeah ah
tragically I think barbecue is kind of
overrated as a food I do
thanks next one brave person right but I
do I mean it's like it's eating a log
you you feel like [ __ ] your sweat for
the whole day you're burping up mesquite
you what you think give it to you on you
eat it on like the top of a garbage can
lid you eat it like a raccoon in an
alley you wait seven hours for a pit
master what that sounds terrifying yeah
it's it is very hostile and then they
give it to you and then you just eat it
crouched like by a garbage can in a
field and everybody's like this is the
best thing you'll ever have you know
maybe you're you just turned me vegan it
just happened I never thought I'd go
that way but that's just gonna eat small
salads now for the rest of my life but
I'm gonna go back to doing coke so you
know what you have yes yes are you gonna
get a little bit of both are you gonna
you were a Florida guy when you were in
Florida he's what I never I've moved to
fly yeah but I grew up outside of
Philadelphia okay and I know I went to
Florida and you know there's no laws
there whatsoever yeah
it's a wild well no I I smoked meth with
alligators that's how [ __ ] weird
Florida is it ain't no to Austin that's
real cool you know yeah that's a real
cool place where were you were in like
Tampa yeah I was my drug dealer was
Dusty Rhodes I mean this is years ago
dusty wasn't laying it all out on the
line here you better pay me back brother
I mean you didn't [ __ ] around with him
I'm gonna be honest
red turns to green it's an old wrestling
thing I think there's some wrestling
folks that know this but there they go
they're there they are
yeah this is the Von Erich family came
back to life after all these years the
Von Erich family was the royalty of
Texas wrestling yeah and then Vince took
them in and named them the Texas tornado
and then killed him
I saw I saw him yeah when I was a little
kid I saw him in Madison Square Garden
in his land one of his last matches
before he did well that's exciting stuff
to miss yeah this is what are you derrin
overdose how did he die
old age in the wrestling business people
just died Tim they don't live past 38 38
that was it is the retirement age for
wrestling thank God yeah thank God are
you still into it because a lot of a lot
of people are still into it
you know I'm an I'm an adult man yeah
gonna lose them are you do you care like
you just ran down [ __ ] barbecue yeah
taxes and then you're like Big Easy we
don't want to [ __ ] and lose these they
love they love their smoked meat and
they love their rat do you care about
any because I don't care about any of it
like that new movie end game coming out
you care about that the movie end game
what is the event where is that yeah I
do care yeah quite a bit I really I
here's here's what happens is compete
like we hey why do people go to these
movies well because men wear backpack
snow right they just a butters growing
up it's like [ __ ] growing up I'm staying
a child
I guess never feeling that a lot of
these people keep like a little tent in
their bedroom yeah so when their friends
sleep over they have a place to go
together it's crazy how many friends I
have that are in their mid-30s and they
have they get in fights about these
movies like arguments vicious who we
talking about Mike Becky own danced over
which were those [ __ ] many guys doing
good those are the successful ones
that's the tragedy of it
dance on three TV shows yes still cares
and then he gets home at night and him
and Becky oh and put [ __ ] mattresses
down here for every drop telling buddies
seriously it's lost something now though
I mean it was cool but you were into it
it was cool thank you very much yes yeah
and it was me and Bruno Sammartino
DiCillo nuts together in you Etta
you opened a comedy club in Tampa what
is this this is your unmasked I'm asking
you now this is it I've done my research
I went on a Wikipedia page five minutes
ago and I read three things that are
prepared to discuss yeah but it was it's
crazy that you you had a comedy club but
comedy was cool right it's not cool
anymore well I mean it's cool but it's
nobody's on drugs nobody's dying you
know what I mean like yeah that's right
like you you were in it when it was
people doing blow you were laundering
money probably not you personally but a
lot of the other places is still
laundering money
yeah I'm right now man and Becky are
just [ __ ] by the way how many people
were to see Aunt Becky go to jail by
applause by a plus one guy one guy yes
why Sir why would you want that justice
real Texas justice yeah that's what
we're after here just would you like to
see her fry where would it end
what is with death penalty be too much
prison tats okay I wouldn't mind seeing
her get get you know ray fogged up okay
you know and today in Texas they
actually executed a person for a crime
that took place twenty-one years ago
that's true twenty one years ago he was
racial murder and now like 21 years
later he's like I think that was me I'm
not sure I get it's a long time ago on
it's a Cory's if right now how do they
do it or do you do an injection now it
is do you still have the chair it's a
headlock they put the person in a
headlock and they just squeeze and
squeeze now you were asking me about my
comedy club yeah I have a Florida doing
this unbelievable bond mask excuse me
I'm a little bit yeah yeah silly with a
real you know taste real taste of what
it's about
dude I've changed my name three times no
one's gonna ever [ __ ] Know Who I am I
don't know who I am anymore you know
these aren't my fingerprints had to keep
moving
yeah you know that's like Florida you
just keep I have a cousin who lives in
Florida she moves to a different town in
Florida every six months yes and it's
always a town that sounds a lot nicer
than what it is it's always like Crystal
River or Sandy Springs and if you go
there you're like oh right this is not
that the real name the real name would
be trailer park junction yeah watch out
everyone here has a knife yeah she said
to me once she was living at Delray
Beach and she said to me we had lunch at
a Chili's and she said you know I love
you and I love the family but I just I
love heroin and yeah yeah where do you
go from there all right I get it
here's the thing just before you mock it
do it because I'll tell you right now
it's a great feeling yeah especially if
you're in Florida there's no reason not
to right
it cuts through the humidity yeah I
remember thinking I remember that heroin
I'm like oh yeah it's the spine that
[ __ ] everything up so much better now
the young people when I know you guys do
different kind of opiates and you're
doing this thing
a little tip for you because everyone in
history is the morphine but you're the
only generation that dies it's a great
so long yeah cheers the 10th right stay
the [ __ ] away that's it that's the end
no one who's awake dies it's the lazy
[ __ ] who just drifts off and forgets
to breathe stay awake and I wish I could
go into schools and teach that I think
you can well be arranged there's some
stupid rule they have about keeping me I
think seventy yards away from ever any
school that's fascism thanks Hillary
yeah you're welcome
Hillary this president I've heard much
about the president know when you when
you you've been doing your radio show
for crazy amount of time I talked to you
the other day you said make-a-wish kids
would come in for the to do the show I
mean you'd realize that it clearly had
nothing to do with them I'm not there we
would get a thing that says the
make-a-wish kid wants to come in on a
titty bar Thursday only forget to say I
was it was a shock jock I was a shock
jock and we say oh yeah sure bring the
kids in and now it would be their dad
that would really and I'm gonna be
honest about this it was their weekend
dead it wasn't a dad who stayed with the
family
yeah now I just say guy that saw an
opportunity yeah I mean the weekend dad
the divorce dad is he really the dad you
know what I mean like yeah I would have
gotten divorced but I like to keep my
weekends free Tim I don't want to I
don't want to go to miniature golf and I
don't want to find out what you want to
do this weekend scooter you know I mean
I was like no I stayed with your mom mow
the lawn dude that's the [ __ ]
difference between me and your friend's
dad's I'm in it long haul were there any
were there any make-a-wish dads that you
thought were cool dudes when they came
in no no they were Floridians it was
every and all of them were bad dude
every lip we've had a giant showdown in
Florida and every listener I had at
eight or nine fingers
they were always yeah you would shake a
listeners hand and just joke back you
know what I mean just every time just
strange lizard hands yes it's a weird
thing that happens the people that were
born and raised in Florida lose at least
one digit how do they even know how no
they just wake up in a fingers gone Stan
probably black market don't say this
you've gotten more out of me than anyone
has yeah Tim it's a skill it's a real
skill he's the rising star in comedy
right now everybody loves a few more
years to live yeah it's gonna rise and
fall and by the way I think you're two
years past due great amazing great
you're funny you know you are my
biological father yes I was gonna wait
till the end to throw that out just
because I had sex with your mom doesn't
make me your father that she was in
Florida she's a Florida woman Florida
and I can tell you for a fact that was
anal yeah and I also I hope and pray and
by the way I was the one getting it
that's how [ __ ] that's how wild man
Tim he was tagging Ron Bennington that
is something that I will always remember
yeah that's why I got into this business
my mother said I pegged a great
broadcaster and you should she remembers
me that way that's wonderful she's a
great woman she was in floor she was a
mermaid in Florida in the Weeki Wachee
yeah right yeah legit she was she was
real trash this is not she was
legitimate and truckers would go and
watch these mermaids and like jerk off
to them before strip clubs opened right
in like the late afternoon early you
know and then she would just swim around
in the tank and that was what she did it
so my grandmother went that sword doing
this it was like good god what are you
doing you are disgracing everybody look
those Weeki Wachee mermaids are [ __ ]
royalty down there they're kind of the
Kennedys
of yeah of Florida but what there would
there would be like a vine right and
there it was an air hose in the vine and
they would reach over on the air hose
and go back to [ __ ] dancing that was
amazing I you know Jim's quick so I
didn't see the whole side you know it
was the Nutcracker for methods that were
people smoking meth in a parking lot
loved it every once in a while the
mermaid would just pop at it and
everybody would go crazy but that was
are you making this up no that was legit
what she did that was her job that was
her job
yeah now for a few years yeah and that
Weeki Wachee is also where sehun was
filmed back in the 1960 what is sehun
sehun was a big this kind this guy no
see huh instead Lloyd Bridges this is
the bridges brothers yeah right and he
was a guy who was a scuba diver but he
would solve underwater crimes and it's
been amazing it was an amazing TV show
cuz every week somebody would cut his
air hose it was like watch that [ __ ]
he's gonna cut your air hose and then he
did it and they also did the Tarzan
movies the same place but when the movie
companies left they just let the monkeys
loose what is what I'm still stuck on
underwater crime your water crime could
possibly take place underwater thanks of
a criminal nature yeah I cut in a boat
line could be that kind of thing
somebody could be stealing underwater
treasures sure no I mean it wasn't
exciting it was an exciting show an
oddly canceled mid episode but you know
life you know it was mega I mean let
that those were the days that's what
people loved you know yeah that's what
we're trying to get back to now yes that
is the greatness we're trying to see if
we can recapture Trump wants to take us
back to see hunt and flipper which was a
dolphin Maga yeah later
yeah MacGyver came later but
flipper was a dolphin that solve crimes
and then these are all Florida shows and
then general Bend was a bear that solves
crimes in the Everglades and a gentle
Ben
yeah gentle Ben that was his it was
Ronnie Howard's little brother was the
star of the show
maybe the ugliest baby that ever lived I
mean just scary scary [ __ ] but every
week does bear and the Everglades would
just [ __ ] raise up on somebody they
would fall backwards and that would be
the end of the episode was the whole
thing yeah it was the whole thing so I
mean Florida brought a lot of arts to
this country and we appreciate it yeah
and I'm trying to think what they've
done recently I don't think they have
anything recently I don't think there's
it new no Florida show in a while that I
know know well normally what you have is
bath salts pretty much ruined the arts
yeah you have like a guy ate another
guy's face those are the best headlines
Florida man well then we'll also the
bass hall headlines are always like
woman chokes pitbull right you know
right so it's very it's a great visual
on whatever all right everybody this is
Tim Dylan here I know this episode is a
little old the great Ron Bennington at
Moontower I know maybe some of you are
aware of the me locate me lily innopolis
invited by the Legion of skanks the most
offensive podcasts on earth to be a
guest on their show at the Creek in the
cave in Long Island City and we had many
many Open Mic comedians between the ages
of 40 and 50 whose careers have not gone
exactly the way they planned getting
very angry at Luis Gomez and others and
then tweeting and yelling and screaming
and threatening to beat people up and
put on our stop and boots and we're
gonna go down there and [ __ ] a lot and I
will say this it would be hilarious to
see Luis get attacked by two fat
lesbians with green hair if Ralph got
hit with a bike lock come on if Dave
Smith for the [ __ ]
outside of the creek with numchucks
you're telling me you couldn't laugh at
that but sadly we will not see that none
of that will materialize because it is
being moved to an undisclosed location
because people cannot handle a guy who I
think is a clown and it said some
ridiculous things but they can't handle
him sitting in the downstairs in a
Mexican restaurant for an hour with
legion of skanks last year emilia
annapolis was on bill maher show he
thought he was gonna be doing Radio City
he's at the creek in the Cape that is
the punishment by the way the punishment
is to have him sit there and say this is
where it's at okay so that's the reality
that's my little take on things if you
are angry about somebody sitting down
and being interviewed on a podcast in a
Mexican restaurant you are an
irredeemable loser
there's nothing that can be done really
to help you and I know that and listen
there are people that I respect as
comedians
that I think are funny that take a
different viewpoint as me or and are
they irredeemable losers probably
probably if you cannot if you're afraid
you do not vanquish people's ideas by
vanquishing people if you don't agree
with somebody you debate them you give
them the opportunity to hang themselves
you show that your ideas are better
because the only thing that after that
the only thing that's left is violence
and fighting which again could have been
fun and funny but won't happen now but
I'm not a fighter I'm a lover I'm
actually just a talker but if you want
it to be a lover you should take blue
chew many of you were running around
your dicks don't work I try to [ __ ] 19
year olds all the time they've been on
medication since their children for
anxiety for depression their dicks
aren't hard they get Hafeez they rub
their dick against you they just want to
cuddle they're so broken as people their
spirits have been trampled they can
barely take lights and sensory motion
going on they just lay there like
adderall puppies so they need a little
boost and the boost is blue true if you
go to blue true calm you can get the fur
chewables with the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
chewables can work faster than pills up
to twice as fast okay
less hearing me talk in that case the
tuples from blue tube can be taken on a
full or an empty stomach you go online a
consultation with a physician is free it
is cheaper than the other two it only
takes a few minutes to connect with a
blue - affiliated physician are they
real doctors who cares it doesn't matter
yes probably they are the point is this
there's no in-person doctor visit you
don't have to see a fancy doctor with a
degree hanging on as well you get to
speak to a Russian bot who will say that
you need this medication and then give
it to you
these two bowls from blue two are
prescribed online by a doctor in quotes
blue true gives you confidence every
time in bed you and your partner are
going to love it I'm telling you
especially if you're on ninety
medications just a function the dick
doesn't work it's very very tough to get
a real hard dick when you're older and
you know the terror of what life really
is because you're riddled with anxiety
who knows so a great deal for you visit
blue true comma get your first order
free when you use promo code TD just pay
five dollars shipping that's blue2 comp
remote code t-- d BL you shoot comp
remote code TD first five dollars
shipping first order free BAM there was
a Florida story the other day that I
just loved that a bird kicked a man to
death he was raising some giant EMU
tripe diapered and he made the mistake
of falling down and the bird ran in him
he had these big razor claws and just
kicked him til he just get him to death
yeah and that guy was the governor of
Florida yeah Texas is so glad there's a
Florida yeah that's so true look it
takes the heat off of every hand by the
way you drinking the rainwater that you
know I love it I have a little bit
upstairs I don't want to get too drunk
on you know the natural world right at
this point of the day but one of the
things I love about Florida is people I
was at a Denny's there this was about
four months ago and the Danny
now has food that doesn't even make
sense like it doesn't even sound good
but it should like they have salted
caramel banana cream pant kit like
nobody even would ever want this and
people in Florida will go and house a
serving of that and then do a Marlboro
Red hundred right outside and there's
something so beautiful about watching
somebody do a hundred not even a regular
cigarette yeah
which takes a 100 takes three minutes to
smoke and to just stand there and really
go for it well you know I mean it's
still recent you recently you could
still smoke in the restaurant yeah
during the meal and you know it's an
amazing time yeah those times are gone
thanks to Obama yeah you said in your
comedy club there was so much smoke you
would see somebody on stage who would
have smoke coming out of his mouth but
he wasn't even smoked yes my comics
would be breathing in so much cigarette
and cigar smoke that they would be
huffing it back out during the show yeah
and you know we refused that ventilation
you're like a big vape they we asked one
hole but that's okay cuz secondhand
smoke is [ __ ] I mean this is true I
really lost and it's true okay relax
nobody's videoing this they're gonna
[ __ ] replay it later again in trouble
your shitty job right it's human
resource it the we work next door we
work you know what you don't
I hate we work you don't like beef yes
we work rich kids who go to Coachella
and they're all coked out their fathers
like let me get you in office
you've got 32,000 Instagram followers
let's have an office you know figure out
something you should have a stapler
it'll turn it all around
I hate we work [ __ ] you if you work it
we were I tweet Isis locations of we
work all day I'm like you should see
what they're doing to the profit at this
we work on Congress they are really
disrespecting the Prophet and nothing I
think this Isis thing kind of overblown
to be honest all day I hate we work I
hate it I'll just say this Tim you
weren't made for these times no
this is not this it was made for Tampa
so I keep saying so I keep asking about
Florida yeah you were bowling up there
these the kind of sports I like ball
with billiards you know what there's a
little I just bolted 229 I couldn't
believe it before I haven't picked up a
ball thank you very much natural athlete
yeah you know I'm I met a young lady
outside who told me that when she was 17
she came to one of my shock jock shows
where are you darlin I can't I can't say
in this light she's still alive
she was 17 doing I think was that the
let the puppies breathe tour that we
were doing wait wait why yes this was
the actual thing that you the women had
to show their tits to get in I should
also remark this was before the me to
movement when we just called it that
this is normal yeah it was a celebration
of women's bodies and independence yes
and also I only have one line left so
you're doing it off my dick yeah was uh
and that is fair that is fair that is
fair people always ask how you make
girls that was my way yeah I've got one
line left yeah when it off my dick yeah
it's great and the t-shirt that would
sell out in Tampa in three minutes right
you know I I had a titty bar tool you
know I was kind of the shark tank guy of
Tampa yeah you have all their needs
covered right but I had a titty bar
called the third trimester and it's
specialized I'm not one of these people
who gets turned off by a woman's body
you know what I mean I find find the
whole thing to be beautiful yeah but a
girl was dancing on stage at my club and
her water broke and I said look we got
nobody else just staying yeah until
Mercedes can get here Mercedes staged
and staged them yeah not the real name
and she just continued dancing
dancing until you know luckily we had a
girl so probably that mother got on
stage and started started showing her
tits we love you mom was your mom a
mermaid or a shark if she was had a fin
yeah mermaids have fins too don't think
I don't think I think they just have the
tail oh I was considered that a fin
we've in the last couple moments I think
it was the third trimester talk
I believe we lost this audience yeah
they're gone
they literally mentally left they're
actually a mentally laughs their army
crawling their way back into the street
they're gone they're back there at a
vegan taco shop up the Straits listening
to poetry yeah I got news for you Tim I
thought this was gonna do it go a lot
better yeah I agree and I think these
people are very tough they're very hard
you know what happened it's this third
person that they set the mic up for
Kevin Hart doesn't show up this guy
doesn't come doesn't call nothing no
email for this guy this is this was my I
always I put out an extra mic for Nipsey
Hussle yeah and I go you know what
brother so we're never gonna forget you
yeah pour up pour out some spring water
for Nipsey Hussle this isn't spring it's
rain yeah these cops outside bring them
in it's as good as any water I don't
know it's it's it's probably a venue
decision that I didn't question I mean
when we walked onstage remember we had
no chairs no chairs and I saw the thing
and I go oh is he doing that
dick ventriloquism bit yeah he used to
do that's what I'm gonna open mic night
that's what I was gonna slide over here
do a voice slide back do a voice who is
the person that you have had calling
your show the most over the years where
you think about them at night and you're
like [ __ ] oh my god that person like
what person are you just completely like
is there one person with you like Christ
where is that person or do you know
because they still keep calling well uh
there was a a guy who he was a crank
caller and he crank called me on the
night of 9/11 know this is the worst a
night before it or the night no the
night off as we're going through people
are looking you know because we were in
local New York radio and people were
looking for their relatives and stuff
and he [ __ ] crank called that night
so I had never met him before his name
is the radio shark he's uh yeah he's a
complete [ __ ] degenerate I mean he's
really he's like one of the worst people
ever so I [ __ ] him I was like so you
know I just yelled at him and [ __ ] I'd
never met him before you remember the
prank do you remember what well I really
can't but we left being feds were on the
air and matter of fact Gail was a little
girl and she was on just sitting in with
us cuz I couldn't get her back home I
was running around grabbing my kids at
school and with her you know the trains
they shut the trains down yeah so I just
brought her to work with me so we go to
leave that night and there was a guy
after I'd yelled because I was like calm
down you know I was like you know radio
tough what I like to call radio it's up
and I come outside and there was a guy
that was like six foot four just a big
beefy guy big holy [ __ ] I have to fight
this [ __ ] guy imagine the cops
responding to that you have no idea
what's going on a radio shock jocks
beating the [ __ ] out of somebody
no I was gonna lose this fight yeah but
my thing was I was gonna go right for
his day I was just gonna slam as they
break his name and then run you know I
mean because again Florida training it's
unbelievable Florida was our Vietnam I
think people in America should remember
that uh but here it wasn't him and it
was just a big guy who was looking for
someone to connect to and he said to me
that he was scared as a little kid I'm
as scared as a little kid now and I said
well the word is gay that's where I kept
them
no I didn't yeah well I didn't say that
because you can't anymore here's the
thing I was the first person in America
I was the first white but 9/11 9/11
changed you well it made a lot of people
mad at Arabs not you
yeah whoa well I don't think it was all
Arabs was it how did it work out there I
know you're struggling with this ya know
I don't know it's probably some Jews too
I would guess I mean yeah you tubes and
I've watched right late at night one of
them look like Voss yeah probably rich
vos and if we're honest we're gonna be
really honest when people are like oh
you know you know you should like Jews I
go alright I want you to meet a guy
Jewish guy like he's really well he's
Jewish but he's like no I've never been
another Jewish guy who like smoked crack
for years he's put up in this beautiful
hotel and I just saw him screaming at a
desk clerk today because there's no free
breakfast
yeah he's got a point he's got a pretty
[ __ ] solid point
[ __ ] you aloft no he's a loft hotel oh
he's in a nice she's at the inner cover
you would yum at the loft like a can
like a scumbag
yeah the loft room shouldn't be seen
before 3:00 a.m. yeah like you look at
those rooms you're like oh I should be
looking at this on Molly at 2:30 in the
morning
there's just at the loft there's a
mirror that's down and a razor there
just in case yeah just in case you ever
did yeah for a while you ever do the
thing where you're just chopping you
look down in the mirror and you see
yourself yeah Wai ghin blossom CD case
sorry I was a professional yeah
chin blossom CD case you ever do this
you ever go in like a long run and
you're [ __ ] just [ __ ] whacked out
and the Sun has already come out by the
time you're driving home and you know
last night's clothes just feel dirty all
of a sudden yeah and you stopped at a
red light and you just see a bunch of
kids getting ready to get on a school
bus yeah and you did nap no no
absolutely absolutely no - absolutely
the good old days
yeah are you ever planning on being a
father that no no no I don't think so
you know would have to have to be a real
reason like there'd have to be a show or
something yeah like a reality show where
they were like oh you have an Asian kid
and the kids teaching me stuff good you
can't afford an Asian kid yeah that's a
good point I can afford a Florida kid I
will only be a father if I could adopt a
Floridian yeah just a Tampa kid yeah
just a white-trash kid 11 years old
smoke cigarettes already those kids are
great yeah selling yep
dumping paprika on oranges I don't know
why but I always say delicious spice on
mangoes but the thing is this I respect
Acacio Cortez and her people outside
they would break their necks trying to
get selfies with her this whole [ __ ]
city would grind to a halt
trying to get selfies with a Jose it
would be [ __ ] why do you waste your
time doing anything but Fox News they
would they would love you we did they
canceled the show that we were all on
called redeye at 3:00 a.m. which was a
great show you see - two degenerate
white supremacists are in the crowd who
watched it and and it was fun because it
was fun it came on at 3:00 a.m. so if
you were watching that you had real
problems I yeah and you know me and
Bonnie McFarlane would go on and pretend
we knew about the news and people would
be you know coming down from a meth
binge working in a factory looking at me
and Bonnie like well those guys will
figure it out yeah what was I got
cancelled sadly they canceled that show
hard to believe it's shocking if the
time in the night there were no ratings
so how would anyone know you know I mean
they they turn off the machines that
time yeah I know I just think they just
said we could make
more money with an infomercial and they
just played the infomercial you know
yeah yeah but you know that one of those
infomercials is where I got my legs so
god bless him for red I was a good shell
because every now and then you'd be in a
green room with people that you
shouldn't be near like I Megan I would
and they give you like free brownies and
I would eat like half of a brownie and
leave it in the makeup chair and then
megyn kelly would be like whose brownie
is this and I'd have to go oh that's
mine and she'd go can you come take it
take the brownie covered in saliva off
the makeup station yeah and sit there
and and then we'd go on TV with like the
National Security Adviser like what's
your plan for Syria and I'm like well
let me tell you right and then if you
put and then you would be with all these
women who were like miss Tallahassee and
they'd all be nice in the greenroom
they'd all be like you know I love
pageants and my parents were in a pen
and then they would Dave turn on the
cameras and they'd be like Hillary's a
devil
she's kids at she writes and you'd be
like whoa whoa rein it in I don't know I
yeah I think you guys are onto something
yeah I agree I think it was fun yeah
folks how many times I have to tell you
to come see me live I mean how many
times everyone who comes to see me alive
has a great time it's a good event it's
a fun experience okay it gets you out of
your home away from your wife and
children and family or maybe you can
bring them I don't care but it just gate
breaks up the routine it's a nice thing
to do when I come through your town
treat it like an event treat it like a
special thing here comes this con man
here comes this grifter let him sling
his jokes here comes this guy selling an
elixir that will cure all of our our
ailments that's who I am I'm just a
grifter I'm just a depression-era tent
circus carnival salesman that's all I am
all I am very happy being that all I am
is the ringmaster of the circus I'm
coming through your town we're pitching
the tent
bringing in the bearded lady we're
bringing in the baby in the jar we're
bringing in the half guy half snake okay
all of those things all those people me
so make sure you get out and you come if
you want to see where I'm performing you
can go to Tim Dylan's going to hell calm
tim TI m dillon di ll OMS going to hell
calm there is no is in this site and i
want you to look at this site because I
made it using Wix Wix is so [ __ ] easy
okay if you need a website and you do
you can choose from either 500 stunning
templates or start from scratch they
have a very innovative drag-and-drop
website builder so you can easily
customize your site you could add text
images videos whatever you want you can
even use their Wix Adi which is
literally [ __ ] futuristic wild stuff
you answer a few questions about what
your website should be and they're gonna
give you some options I'm telling you
this is how to do it if you want 10% off
any of their premium plans you have to
go to Tim Dylan's di ll ons going to
he'll calm see where I'm performing I'm
gonna be at Mohegan Sun and tune I'm
gonna be all over the place I'm gonna be
an American comedy company in San Diego
in early August the 1st through the 3rd
in San Diego get your ass is there in
July 4th I think I'm gonna be down in
Key West Florida or in Miami we're still
firming that up we're not sure but you
need a website so many people I talked
to think that everything in social media
so much is social media but you need a
website you do need a website
everybody that's important has a website
Kylie Jenner has a wet maybe not a Wix
website doesn't matter you're not Kylie
Jenner you start with Wix you start with
a cheap functional very
professional-looking alternative you
want to be Kylie Jenner you gotta be on
top of your [ __ ] you have to be you need
a website you need your content out
there in in one place so the people can
go what's this guy about you need fans
from all across the spectrum there's
gonna be boomers that are going to be
your fans boomers the people who raped
this country took all the money took all
the drugs destroyed our credit rating
destroyed our credibility in the world
these people they're happy and
that and drunk all the time playing golf
on cheap borrowed credit they've ruined
this country they hollowed it out from
the inside they were given everything
and did nothing with it but you need
them as fans and many of them love a
website they love the comfortable
website they like to go to a place that
has all I feel acts they're not on
Twitch the boomers aren't on tick-tock
the boomers are at home drinking sangria
they barricaded themselves in the
bathroom because their son is trying to
get in there and steal the rest of their
back medication which is their fault
because they didn't accept them because
he was gay but while they're in that
bathroom calling the police they're on a
website trying to find someone that they
like and want to follow they're not on
these new fangled apps that everybody
knows not watching so you got to connect
with the boomers they're out there
they're gonna retire soon they're gonna
just be annoying and 55 and over
communities in nursing homes [ __ ] on
the floor watching Fox News and
screaming but they will pay for your
podcast if you can find them and they
gotta find you and they're gonna find
you on a website they're not gonna find
you necessarily on Twitter they don't
like Twitter it moves too fast they're
like a nice website they like Facebook
they love Facebook or Facebook is now is
knee operations and dead dogs just dog
carcasses people eulogizing their dogs
this is what it is
GoFundMe and pictures of people's
grandfather was served in the Civil War
thee they're old people they love
Facebook cuz it's a website so if you
want to reach them and they're a huge
demographic and they're underserved by
current cultural commentary not really
but I'm saying if you want to connect
with them if you have a product that
will connect with them okay
like racism or something they'll really
get up get into you got to get a website
folks you do if you go to Tim Dylan's di
ll ons going to hell calm
click the link at the bottom we will
give you 10% off any premium plan be
smart also I've said and I have already
some people know noted that have done
this you'll get three minutes on the
show if you do this and you prove to me
that you've done it you get three
minutes on this show to promote whatever
you're doing we have an audience of tens
of thousands of people whatever you're
doing you can promote it on this show
whether it's a business whatever you get
three minutes and maybe longer if we
like you minimum three minutes
uninterrupted to promote what you're
doing on the show and then we will ask
you follow-up questions and that is if
you can prove to me you went to Tim
Dylan's di ll ons going to hell comm
scroll down to the bottom chose a
premium plan ok got 10% off if you prove
to me that you you did it through my
website or you upgrade your current Wix
site through my website I will give you
three minutes on this show to promote
whatever you're doing and now back to
the legend the goat Ron Bennington now
do you vote I mean I didn't vote last
election I was flying vote like a
lunatic get off a plane start running
around
I don't like polling station I love if I
would vote in a restaurant if at the end
of the meal they were like which one I'd
go oh okay that's Yelp the Bronx to a
polling station stand there in a
gymnasium for an hour and a half you
know come on you've never voted for Bush
once and Obama once and then I gave up
because I'm like none of it really
matters it's all kind of [ __ ] and
really even today don't listen this
one's a little different I guess I mean
people seem to be a bit more emotional
he's this guy's really just kind of
riffing yeah he doesn't seem to have a
ton of prepared material but here's what
I love about what he's funny a problem
he's funny so I don't know here's what I
love though for years yeah I mean we
would never have in New York president
because people would think that New
Yorkers were rude and an [ __ ] and
rightfully so yeah rightfully so but
then you guys in the south
went and picked a guy that even we think
is a rude [ __ ] con man we were like
what the [ __ ] he just destroyed a casino
yeah he his [ __ ] planes fell out of
the air yeah and you guys think you can
run this dump yeah well he's uh you know
that's the funny thing about Austin it's
like liberal but it's still Texas so you
never know where to go with this
ya ever know how far I can go with this
material you know you're like where
where do we land where you know you know
they're liberal Austin is liberal until
it gets to Jesus and like hey right hey
hey hey Christ died for our sin and
lived in Texas and owned a gun and was a
pitmaster yeah you got to go to Christ's
barbecue it's a little stand right in
the middle of a field it's it isn't a
bad area it's a six-hour wait you served
brisket in a coffee cup and you eat it
[ __ ] on the ground like a pig
welcome to our city yeah well you might
love about Texas America looks to Texas
like the rest of the world looks at
America we're like are they cooler
[ __ ] creeps we can't we don't know
you don't know what seemed like really
afraid if you lived here you'd become
this yeah nothing else you really well I
should do this yeah yeah yeah there's no
doubt you know I mean there's like a
comfortability to it yeah yeah there's
something cool about it there's
something cool about just saying that
and that's what's kind of cool that
Florida Florida is what's cool about
Florida is like giving up at 32 right
you know just somebody was 33 years old
going [ __ ] this well [ __ ] the game I I
went to [ __ ] Florida like aged 21
because I'm like I'm not [ __ ] working
you know I mean like right I guess I'm
not a sucker
I just headed down there and literally
started hosting wet t-shirt contests but
that's the American dream awesome yeah
that's amazing and then people would
bring their kids that were sick with
cancer to those contests before I got on
the radio
I was hosting be like it's always been
Bobby's dream to see him quit wins if
any of you have kids that want to get in
the wet t-shirt game here's this one of
our sponsors shut the [ __ ] up okay
we hear it only sell CBD here's here's
the way to win every wet t-shirt contest
come out and dance to you shook me all
night long yeah that's the [ __ ]
winning song and the girls used to fight
over it oh it would fight to see who got
that song cuz I would song was worth
$500 to their wet tits now whoo what a
strategy what was the next song if they
didn't get that what would the next song
be dirty deeds done dirt cheap you had
to have ac/dc to win yeah that's it were
in this audience god bless america
Kate Smith god bless america Kate the
Kate Smith thing you know I was from
Philadelphia Ridge and what happened
she's a big racist she is a she was a
racist ninety years ago but in the 70s
she was our good luck charm and I was
too Stanley Cups but let's be honest
nothing since but what was not good if
you listen to music now it sucks
oh yeah terrible like every woman then
sounded like a transgender person right
yes sounded like me Ethel Merman her
[Music]
it's American baseball and I have a dogs
they all sounded like that they all
sounded like they were on hormones for
[ __ ] six months it is true women have
gotten more feminine
cuz they were very mad yeah I mean she
had the you know I have a plow and then
go out and sing after him it was a very
she was Irish I'm Irish and Irish women
aged like cabbages like that okay
they are very hard scrabble women yeah
yeah so that's something that you have
to look forward to
ya aging like a cabinet well yeah I mean
Irish ladies are my grandmother and a
maid named Terry Terry was an Irish
woman real Irish like all the kids at D
wheeze the other half were cops and
Terry just had varicose veins she smokes
cigarettes and Ashton a seashell she was
always bombed she always called my
grandmother when she got home and went
made it and then just hung up the phone
she was an Irish woman who'd was
disgusting boiled meats and like just
filthy I just loved it made it Oh told
you I could [ __ ] drive drunk without
the seatbelt oh yeah she would literally
they would be the answering machine if
we go but then she's got dotty made it
call me tomorrow right click they lived
on Long Island so she'd show back up
with a [ __ ] basket of oysters yeah
sure she shot back up she was
interesting interesting lady what do you
feel about this new thing we're like
we're looking back and going well that
person was racist 70 years ago we got to
get rid of their [ __ ] like I think
that's what happened recently with
Michael Jackson there was a documentary
it wasn't as a documentary where people
said that he was racist and now they're
taking his music off the air what do you
feel about that maybe if he would have
[ __ ] a couple black kids instead of
all white exactly I got behind that's
what I have said that's what I say that
documentary sucked there was no music in
it I fast forwarded the whole [ __ ]
thing there was a lot of talking I'd
watched it on mute and I don't know what
it is making him look like he's a good
person cuz he helped all these kids who
gives a [ __ ] we get it he's a good guy
okay where are the [ __ ] you know he
[ __ ] a lot of hoes where are they but
it's not one [ __ ] in that [ __ ] thing
you know this guy was [ __ ] hos left
and right it's crazy you've got a whole
new spin on this Tim that I didn't
I'm not hearing anywhere else and I'm
not shocked at redeye is off the air
after that let me say things like that
on redeye and we would very seriously
like the host would be like that's a
good boy now the thing is with Michael
Jackson we all know it everybody said it
then yeah everyone said he's [ __ ]
those kids yes but no one stopped him
right and the reason why everyone went
in the 80s was lazy yeah I don't know I
don't know what happened but it's an
extreme amount of laziness there's not a
single person shocked about this no
one's really surprised about
there are truthers out there the Jackson
truthers what's that what are they
saying well they believe that this is an
elaborate like is there anyone here by
round of applause and we won't we're not
gonna you know you know whatever but it
thinks he could be innocent it's like a
setup okay okay there one person who the
mic did not do this mic is all right so
this guy right here this guy this guy he
just winked at me like I think so I
don't wanna say I won't say anything you
know so we all know it so why don't we
care then I I don't know I mean yeah
it's a great point I wasn't a lot I was
a young kid and he's trying to be an
actor trying to [ __ ] people right i
defunded directors and nobody I was on
Sesame Street Elmo didn't [ __ ] me nobody
[ __ ] me who should have and if you
look at a photo of me back then you'll
be like these people were crazy my peak
from 7 to 7 and a half I was a [ __ ]
tree and then at 8 it started to head in
a Florida direction I'm very solidly in
a mortgage broker direction around 9
like you look and you go all that guy's
gonna sell houses to old people but you
had six beautiful months six months no I
really I I'd say you know
you know I was untouched thank God
that's why I'm broke you know that's why
you're broke because you never had the
chance to sue the church I've never had
this I'm starting to dead one of us weak
Dylan I'm starting to figure out where
his head's at
yeah the church is a big thing no one
stops that can you talk about Michael
Jackson what about the church well you
know Jesus I gotcha that's a fair point
the point is Chris Stanley or Chris
could I get a rain water I'm out of
rainwater yeah ladies and gentlemen the
untalented Jim Dylan the Chris Stanley
is here tonight our surprise guest is
LaToya Jackson so whenever she gets here
to defend her brother I believe that at
a certain point he became Latoya yeah
well that's a lot of people say that
you've never really seen them both in
the same room at the same time those
kids might have yeah but remember Janet
is the one who was out because she's
showed nipple yeah she did
ladies and gentlemen Chris Stanley turn
around and wave to everybody
Hey look out phinny's guy come here
coughs get back here look how thin he's
got look how thin his guys this could be
fun for the rest of the show he runs in
place why are he's so thin yeah he goes
there he goes that he looks great yeah I
want the knees to hit the hands yeah I
really want you to go for it here you're
running like someone that was in a car
accident you're running like my aunt is
in physical therapy
now it's distracting we got to be
careful in this Texas heat yeah hey I'm
doing a show later tonight yes pleat
plug plug it what is my what is what is
Ron show Chris Beddington crowdsources
Antone's at 9:00 p.m.
yeah
rheya cool is that it's a format that I
thought of and then never once tried
what what is the format I don't know I
thought that I could because there was a
lot going on I thought maybe I could
bring those whole country together short
figuring out where all of our opinions
are but literally just like school
didn't know work on it yeah and
sometimes those are the best things
that's a yes
look at Trump this is what he did and
he's now you know killing his kids
unbelievable
three minutes yeah was that three
minutes that's my fitness goal right
there that's amazing I'm like this guy
this guy got off the plane today went
straight to the gym but you look angry
now this is what you look now listen
underneath is roiling rage you are you
are gonna kill a person but you're gonna
look great doing
you're gonna strangle a woman in a hotel
room but you're gonna look phenomenal
you've all done that Tim yeah it's
called love yeah that's not Chris family
that's Vito Vito everybody yeah now I
was just about to say I thought it was
interchangeable yes used whatever name
Vito is a greasy Italian and his family
kills other people for money is that how
it works out yeah so he was born and
raised Italian in New York and I don't
know whether you ever saw the Godfather
I have but his mom was in The Godfather
really yeah that's [ __ ] with my mom
is a merman again this is everybody's
mom was cool real mermaid listen I can
believe what was your mom and the
Godfather hold on in the microphone why
you lie yeah yeah that was right where I
live Jones Beach well yeah that was my
mom it what in the when the turn stop
oh the one who'd shutteth a I'm dropped
yeah wow I thought there was a dude now
that was my mom she
[Laughter]
that's what we meet Italian women look
like masculine women yes she's sang as
she dropped don't [ __ ] chest up
alright leave that [ __ ] back home she's
a good woman you gotta fold the [ __ ]
pizza do the right way we get it John
Travolta you're [ __ ] practicing for a
dance contest
alright you're on edge right now it
still wears the white suit wherever he
goes at night do you really yeah I like
that I like that this isn't your show
this site okay
I love how aggressive is this is what
happens you stop eating carbohydrates
everything's in ant Anstead he's like
have a [ __ ] frozen yogurt here's my
as he has 42 meatballs for [ __ ]
breakfast grant spends the rest of his
day doing Goomba situps don't we all
have guns here so [ __ ] they ain't
just you as Chris's that's great just
Vito's workout video well thanks go take
a [ __ ] you to see leave him alone
what is your eyes yeah it's still light
out this will be light forever that's
what's great about awesome it'll be
light to let midnight what is this
[ __ ] Alaska what's happening yeah I
don't know night to make these people
laugh it's like it feels like a
graduation [ __ ] weird univer lame in
Texas Austin graduation some degree
because they get degrees in like
agriculture and on this horse [ __ ]
stop it you know it's true it's [ __ ]
long horn jerking off or whatever it is
it's [ __ ] genius college is for
losers
period [ __ ] you and pay your student
loans no forgiveness burn in hell by the
way the rest of your life cuz you got a
degree in English you [ __ ] loser
burn in hell for the rest of your life I
didn't do a student loan I took out a
subprime mortgage cuz I'm [ __ ] cool
that was my [ __ ] loan I learned a lot
yeah that's an education no doubt about
it straight up but I have an intern that
she is in college for communications
right yeah basically radio or TV right
the same thing the mediums that are on
the rise and less of her this poor thing
is gonna [ __ ] oh three hundred and
twenty thousand dollars because she's
[ __ ] stupid right and I don't feel
bad for her because she wants to be
Wendy Williams and she's gonna pay 400
grand to figure out that no one gives a
[ __ ] right well if you had kids you do
but yes you had them now participate in
this pretend life that does exist for
you I have outside kids if you had kids
now I got a six month old put are--can
that I'm [ __ ] taking care of on the
other side of town we get it you're a
hero but if you that's all I want to do
is be appreciated well man you tell them
what's the major what's the move in life
dude you don't know because this [ __ ]
changes so [ __ ] fast right now
everything you can't you can't get it
kid prepared for the future what are you
gonna say take up robotics no one knows
what's going to Astrix a great point I
mean I'm lucky that I'm the last person
who will live a full life
without there being terminators or
[ __ ] Martians you know I'm gonna
fight as long as I die by any hand other
than a robot I'm gonna feel like I beat
the game I beat the [ __ ] game cuz I
wasn't a slave to them and you know what
here's what kills me about robots we
[ __ ] knew it since the 1890s right
Jules Verne [ __ ] was bright there
weren't even any machines and he was
like robots are [ __ ] scary you know I
mean he just no no every movie since
then goes the robots are going to turn
on you yet these [ __ ] still keep
making a eyes yeah they don't care cuz
they want us gone they want to get
the people at the top you keep trying to
get me to [ __ ] say [ __ ] okay and they
say red eye red eye goes away this day
is a podcast people bring it up in three
months the other great thing about red
eyes on a tree and there were no records
of it you can't find it right find red
eye you can't yeah say whatever you want
on it
so what do you send who's behind these
robots no it's not the Jews because it's
a group of people very wealthy people
that may or may not be lizards right
that [ __ ] control a lot of different
things that oh you're done that was
that's it I thought that was a carnival
rants no that's it yeah they're the
controllers and they control all right
so we're against them they haven't
offered me anything I don't know if I'm
with them or against I don't know where
I am I can't afford to you know not have
opportunities right you need to serve
the [ __ ] yes over they've learned
from my I didn't take on student loans I
watched in force and what I got from
Thank You Austin for your leadership
yeah and what I understood what I
understand from that is that there are
demons right that are coming to get us
and I don't know how and when but it's
gonna happen and they're they have the
machines and I think a lot of those kids
shut in the schools were faking it I
wish I could have gotten that gig as a
kid I was an idiot Sesame Street I would
have killed that [ __ ] fake shooting
dick I will tell you the truth in the
last five minutes we just got as
offensive as possible if you don't
realize what's going on we just go down
the list of sacred cows and slaughter
them literally when I was a [ __ ] kid
in high school because we had had a
couple races fights you know yeah all
this first no no okay
and on Fridays I always plan these keg
parties during school for everybody to
come in and give [ __ ] a couple bucks
and you know make a little money for me
and I would just call the [ __ ] local
paper and I go I hear Friday there's
gonna be a race for it to school I hope
it's gonna be [ __ ] bloody watch out
for it and it would write it up and then
they would cancel school that day and we
were all free to enjoy our [ __ ] youth
so [ __ ] up you do it now people show
up right yeah but not only beer but
plenty of PCP for the kids that like
angel dust all right and I also sold
this [ __ ] PCP powder and called it th
say go like this it's the best part of
weed you're gonna enjoy this kids have
got to be free to enjoy themselves
that's what I'm sayin when you're [ __ ]
the student loans let him be free let it
be free plug away sir well tonight I
think the show I'm doing is source code
I don't know the name of it crowd source
thank you very much where you guys are
all coming right you're coming to this
show tonight right and bring the energy
that you had here yeah six out of ten
yeah we're gonna bring that bring that
parent-teacher conference energy you
showed up to [ __ ] this thing with
that wind me over energy that we [ __ ]
it working up here pulling every
anecdote we've ever [ __ ] had Jesus
Christ
Tim you brought things out of me that no
one else did I mean you're you're the
next round Barrington you really are
let's hope give it up for romantics and
everybody Sirius XM thank you guys for
coming out have a good night [ __ ]
barbecue